people enjoy it ma'am especially when
happens to other people this is
definitely a factor of schadenfreude
watching something go terribly wrong to
someone else
[Music]
joining you all you're about to start
your first mystery group and driving
down the road you see this side and
another side pay no attention and then
this time lights up and then disaster
strikes you're about to get your 15
minutes of fame all thanks to this man
hi I'm Juergen hen these infamous nice
parts right you're good one could say
that yes
I am no no see 11 foot a guy around here
you get his wife started 11 foot eight
calm which is what exactly
11 foot 8 website records all the truck
crashes that happen here at the 11 foot
8 bridge really all it is 8 years ago I
set up camera outside my office here and
started recording the traffic that goes
under the railroad trestles behind me
within a few weeks I recorded a truck
crashing into the railroad bridge since
installing the camera you're going to
upload a video of 113 crashes at the
bridge and amassed over 10 million views
most bridges in the state have a 15-foot
7-eleven put a bridge whoever because
built a hundred years ago and lower
height and now experienced these crashes
have dedicated follow
our fans are really intensely interested
in these crashes and they love to buy
souvenirs little piece of crash art with
crusher the crash art are bent mangled
pieces of aluminum that usually form the
frame of the truck and the impact rushes
that aluminum and kind of twisted in
interesting shapes people will buy the
crash art they love it for summer room
is almost like owning a piece of the
Berlin Wall whether the town just
breathe truffle or loathe room from the
perspective of the city and the state
d-o-t the low clearance is clearly
marked and it's up to the driver to
decide their next move the structural
changes that the intersection would be
extremely costly well if we have these
awful videos right I get no satisfaction
out of being in you crash it we found an
actual solution to prevent us tomorrow
I'd be all over it I love it
[Music]